you've done dune
ant-man
you've done all these roles
suicide squad comes up and i remember
that james gunn there was a video that
was made
uh it was where uh
him james gunn and dave dave our good
buddy dave were singing
uh a song from what set it up blue
velvet video dreams sequence from uh
blue velvet yes that day yes and who
directed it dave
dave directed it and james played the
dennis hopper character um from blue
velvet and dave played um the um
dean stockwell character i play the kyle
mclaughlin character and
they basically dave wanted to recreate
that incredible sequence from blue
velvet and um
yes and it was amazing it's really
captivating riveting i love it i laughed
my ass off when i saw it because it's
all my friends in the video
and james says
that it's from this little video that
you did tell me if i'm wrong
but he said you had like the way you
were filmed was so unique and you had
such an incredible face
that that's where you popped in his mind
about polka dot man is that true
i believe that is true i believe that he
uh
he i i heard him say that that he was
watching me that night when we were
filming and he was like
i that's that that's it's either that's
my polka dot man or that guy has got
such a crazy look on his face that i got
to do something with with him um and uh
what a gift man what a gift like you
know it's it's it's such a interesting
thing like
i don't think i've ever talked about
work with you i don't know if i've ever
talked about work with j had ever talked
about working with james i think most of
my friends who do what we do it's like
when we get together we're either
playing games or we're talking about
politics or who knows what we're talking
about but it's never like
work stuff so
you just don't think the opportunity the
opportunity
to get to collaborate with your friends
which now after the last couple of years
i am
so [ __ ] committed to like
creating
stories and opportunities where me and
my friends can collaborate because it's
just i'll remember that
i mean seriously dude me and steve angie
are like writing stuff right now i've
got
i write all the time i'm always now from
i'm committed to this because life is so
short man it's so short and i
i love what we do but i would love
i love it even more when you're getting
to like do it with people that you love
and not to say that there's not
wonderful people you meet on the journey
and you meet strangers and they become
your friends but
like how great would it be if we got to
you know
it's that's exactly right to work with
your friends is something special to be
able to hire your friends on something
is is just it's unique it's hard to be
able to do and i mean not really i mean
you could shoot things for free and just
hire your friends and keep doing it and
have fun on all different levels give me
the conversation when james called you
and uh told you you want you you want to
play you texted me he texted you you
texted me i was in uh scotland um i
wrote another film with a mutual friend
of ours uh i didn't write it with her
but she starred in it um called all
creatures here below which karen gillan
um stars in yep and so i was in
scotland at the glasgow film festival
presenting the movie so we were like six
hours ahead of maybe seven hours ahead
of james
and he texted me it's kind of late for
me like 11 or 12 at night and he said i
want you
to be part of the suicide squad
and i was like because i knew he was
making the movie and i was so excited
because i i just loved the idea of james
gunn making the suicide squad and um
so then i called him right back
and
you know he was like i want you to play
polka dot man and i was like i i you you
know this about me i'm a huge comic nerd
i've been collecting comics my whole
life and i know nothing about the polka
dot man i mean nothing about the thrill
right i was thoroughly embarrassed
because i've always
been excited at the prospect that if i
ever got like a big role in like a
superhero movie i'd be the guy that
would be like oh well which phase are we
talking about was it you know and who
which writer were we what was your
inspiration and i was like but you knew
nothing
i knew nothing and then
he sent me the script
and it was just
it was so beautiful man it was so
incredible and i um
he didn't know this about me but i have
um
vitiligo these spots can you see them on
the camera a little bit yes yep
um and
um
i
so it's kind of a white patch like white
patch i have right patches basically all
over
my body that haunted me as a kid and
were
you know the things that we think others
are judging us by or care about you know
are so
just we're so wrong so much the time but
that that was something that really i
got i did get picked on about it and um
and i had polka dots uh spots milk
mustache i had a lot of bad nicknames
but um
i
said to him like you don't even know how
incredible this role this opportunity is
and
not to mention the fact that i have this
fight and he was like i don't even know
about him he's like i've been friends
with you for
at that point
five or six years maybe he was like i
had no idea